and Tick Tock I'm again I'm not
defending I don't think it's a great
idea to have kids on social media all
day I don't think that's a phenomenal
move right like I don't think it's great
like but I also think like this myopic
view where we look at like this company
and say this is corrupting our children
and ignore the poison food and we ignore
like so many other things
and again I don't care ban it I don't
have any followers
it doesn't [__] bother it doesn't
[__] bother me you can all [__]
dump in podcasting don't pay on YouTube
don't do that but
I love the things that they think are
like universally good you know I like
the universe look good you know I don't
know it's like
so Tick Tock collects I think roughly
the same type of information as Facebook
and Twitter that's what they claim
they're saying like hey
you know that's a lot of like data it's
the information about the videos you
watch comments you write private
messages you send
and
so here's what they think it's doing get
play the kid out who identifies as a
hawk this is what
this is what they're worth they think
that China and by the way maybe China is
doing it I don't know they're they're
saying that China is
pushing these weird
theories or whatever so this is why they
worry about people getting radicalized
on Tick Tock this is a person
who is I don't know if this is real
I don't know anymore I don't I don't
know what is and isn't real anymore so
if I play this and then you comment this
is actually a practical joke I'll go
life is a practical joke I don't know
anymore this is a person that is
claiming
to be I believe a hawk which is kind of
cool now what people are worried about
is maybe they think and maybe this is
true China is making our children into
Hawks
so let's watch this
my name is Horus and I'm a red-tailed
hawk in our world I do have the body of
a hawk but while fronting I consider
myself a Therian because I am in a human
body but my identity is still a hawk not
all animal Alters will identify this way
and I am in fact the only animal alter
in our system who does identify this way
I am doing my best to come to terms with
living in a human body
okay
um is there anything more about this uh
this user they have a lot of like Neo
pronouns so let's watch a neopronoun
post okay here we go
listen
we're learning get your ass off Twitter
[Applause]
I like this
don't you kind of want your kid to be a
hawk
wouldn't Republicans like that like like
hardcore right-wing people my kid's not
trans they're a hawk
it's not great that many of our children
think they're Hawks but I don't think
that's a lot of them but I will come out
and say that I will I will say this
right now
and I don't think this will be a
controversial point and yet I'm sure it
will be I don't believe it is a positive
development in our society that some of
our children are under the impression
that they are birds
that is not a
positive development
in our society